yeah people who don't know uh I know you
from snowfall all right all right which
is obviously one of the more legendary
television shows of the last I don't
know forever yeah yeah it's one of them
once it's one of them ones um but I did
not know that you made music so what
were you doing first acting with music
it was always both so I'm um I came up
at a church that was in the middle of
the 20s called first African Methodist
Episcopal Fame okay um out of it came
1500 or Nothing so rantsing them yeah
all from that same church Jammy and so
I've always been musically inclined it's
just everybody else is better than it
around me right so I didn't think like
you know when you when you're hanging
around goats you often think that your
talent is minimized right but then you
also get to Stepping around other people
and you're like wait hold up I might
have something I'm actually like they're
so amazing that I'm better than
everybody else well I could be possibly
right if you put the work in in time but
I've always been doing music I've been a
songwriter since I was 15 I got my first
placement at 16 years old what was your
place of it man I ain't wrestling and
got that I got that for me oh word yeah
it was a blessing it was um I think it
was on the TV show or something
like a 90210 or something like that yeah
my first song independently it was dope
so obviously living in La a lot of
people come here to start acting what
was the origination of you like being an
actor and like actually making a career
out of it oh [__] my mama bro like mama
grandma uh my community even my church
like in church plays you know my mom
always was like trying to find different
ways to keep me distracted off the
streets and it didn't work but she tried
her best and this was one of the things
that's that always um stuck Wendy Raquel
Robinson I gotta give her a flower she
had a school in the hood for acting
um Amazing Grace Conservatory which is
still active to this day and basically
she gives grants out to certain kids who
she believes is talented to kind of
Foster and give them a conservatory
level of training right and um at a cost
which was no cost for some people to be
honest and that's produced like I think
the dude who was in Moonlight and like
me yeah she she didn't produce music or
everybody everybody you came out of
there yeah I did and before that it was
Faith acting so it was Faith acting then
AGC and they were kind of the same so it
was there and then um yeah it just kind
of kept me out out the way well it tried
to keep me out the way yeah
um how because I the ACT obviously I'm
involved in the music industry and the
music industry
is such it's a lot of it's like hitting
the lotto but for whatever reason the
acting game to me feels like even more
difficult to get like into oh yeah
numerically I mean if you look at the
people first of all music don't have no
Union so that's not I probably just
everyone moves to LA and like it's like
not all of y'all getting in the movies
bro oh yeah no I think it's less than
one percent of the SAG Union works
that's great it's a job a year and I've
been blessed enough to always work with
that didn't come from no like you know
knowing nobody I want nobody nephew or
son or anything I was just me and and
blessed enough to have people see me
working along the way so what was your
first big break on the acting side first
Big Break
[__] well I made my first big break to
me was when I made my first feature I
was 17 years old I wrote director start
in it because I didn't know no better
right and um I won this Grant from
Panavision I was like 17 years old it
was supposed to be for college students
but I didn't know so I do apply
unapplied and I and they gave me this
big ass film camera and so I had to
learn how to like cut film like like my
fingers you shot your own [__] like yeah
yeah like really I was on super 16. I'm
shooting my first feature I started it
directed it um but I always had a love
for Cinema I always had a love for music
right so I just that was like a mode of
expression for me like even when you
said like oh the music industry or the
film industry that should be weird to me
because that's not my I don't have like
actor friends I didn't get active
friends till later I had like friends
who like we throw going away parties and
those going away parties just to turn
themselves in so yeah yeah that's my
friends like so I didn't even as I was
being successful even when like I'm
going to Telluride or whatever and the
homies ain't never heard of that [__]
right you know what I'm saying but like
I'm talking about you know Bernardo
Bertolucci you know [__] don't really
know what the [__] I'm talking about but
you know they supported me they love me
I always got love so I just kept doing
it but the industry the commodification
of art I still don't get that [__] I
don't know how you navigate it I don't
know how my manager Chris Cornish
navigated I don't know how [__] do
that I just make [__] and been blessed
enough and people like it yeah well
sometimes but like really I just I
bother [__] because I ain't [__] is
scarier and ain't no no scary ain't
nothing scarier than death so I'll be
pressing like I'm making my [__] I'm
going and if people like it they like it
so
um how did you initially get into
snowfall obviously John Singleton was
behind I mean God Rest the soul rest in
peace to John Singleton
um but you're obviously very imperative
early in the show what was the process
of getting on his radar and getting
casted in that show well I had known
John since I was 16 17 years old because
of that movie I told you about right so
when I made it I was also working at
Sony pictures under the head of physical
production named Gary Martin he gave me
the opportunity to learn the business of
filmmaking because he I was bothering
him so he was like you know it was an
internship that I found I snuck on a lot
right Jesus that's crazy yeah it was
crazy it was really wild out here you
know I was a ditch I was going to summer
school at Hamilton and ditching so you
were interning on the movie lot yeah but
nobody really knew how old I was so they
just like let me do [__] and I knew what
I was talking about but they didn't know
I was a kid kid so I was getting checks
like 16 15 years old that were looking
like nice like not crazy bro but
something for a 15 year old kid in 10
bands you like [__] I'm up and my
family living in a section I'm like I'm
up so for me making that feature film
there were other people like Gary Martin
who had built the careers of minority
filmmakers he's a white dude look like
Santa Claus right but he always enabled
black Latino and female filmmakers from
the ninth like Robert Rodriguez like all
him and John and he thought that I
reminded him of John and John he would
tell John I got this kid I got this kid
but until I made my first feature John
wasn't trying to hear it so when I
finally made my first feature got on the
front of New York Times John was like
okay I'll listen to this kid you feel me
and um we clicked because he did know
who Bernardo Bertolucci was right he did
know you know what what burger stand not
to go to in South Central Los Angeles
and he knew books and he knew music and
he like people don't know John on the
record label and the first person he
ever signed was um I was an a dog crazy
yeah that's like he been that [__] like
it's it's always been intertwined it's
never really been separated and you know
like if you know the history of La you
know was he also working with Coolio
yeah at some point yeah yeah he got he
really go crazy like I had um I had the
music music director dude um for the
show on uh the white dude from from
Compton what's his name yeah yeah Jon
Stewart he for real I ain't gonna lie he
been outside like he's been outside
right but yeah no that so so you're like
a real just film geek I mean you got to
be a geek about this [__] to really like
put your own movie out as a kid I mean
[__] I'm like that with music too like I
like my like so are you editing your own
movie I did at that time yeah now now
it's like it's too easy like I'm saying
when you're like so like back in the day
did you have Final Cut like back in the
day it was Avid and now you still have
Avid but back then there was these
massive systems that you had to edit on
just like like musically right here and
it's like no it used to be crazy now
anybody can buy a little red box from
Guitar Center and but Just Like Music
everything used to be tape everything
used to be analog you had to cut it
right if you wanted that analog feel so
I was actually I remember my first film
I cut like on like a like a like a star
you were actually like studying the film
and then the next film I did like on
Avid which is like ingesting these
massive things
um I shot on film I did all that I've
done my work like I really been out here
probably didn't have to but but that was
I loved it when you love some [__] you
don't even know that you're supposed to
be doing certain things to industrialize
to um solidify a career or political I
never did the politics very well even in
music like that's why it took me so long
to transfer over and do this EP which is
on Street journals volume one June 23rd
and um you you know I got these big
features and everybody's like oh my God
who was on your EP like bro if I gotta
tell you off camera because this is a
surprise you're here to promote it who
is this can I tell them where am I
holding that it's a big one
you can tell well you can't you can't
put it in though you got to beep it you
gotta you gotta beep it will beep it so
my the next single I'll play it for you
oh [__]
and then the next one me and Wally we
just shot a video today oh shout out to
Wally yeah it's crazy it's gonna go
crazy like it's suffice on you people to
go crazy like it's really different damn
that's a pretty uh
that's a pretty serious feature to get
is this your first EP it's my second one
the first one was red flags it was red
flags was more like a um like a like a
gritty r b
would you consider like your movie
career is helping you fund your music
career now because obviously 100
everything but everything right like
because I you know my movie career you
know acting I make a bag that's for the
family
um but I make people don't know like I'm
Diversified I have a real estate
investment trust I got like at some
point I had Equity stake in the luxury
car business during the pandemic because
you know all the finesses and drug
dealers wanted to rent cars oh yes they
did I made a bunch of money doing that
but when when you say make a bunch of
money it's not like a flex it's like I
would I would I took I just basically
took money I was gonna go spend to go
buy a dumb car and and went and invested
in a company that I had a bunch of cars
so that like whatever's not on the lot I
would just use that so that was fun
because I got to experiment with cars
and see what I liked it's never really
motivated by me trying to like you know
look fly it's more so me like how do I
not lose this money so I do that I gotta
um but that's all just business ventures
to make sure that my mom my grandma my
son my my seed has something but the
music was always just a passion that I
love to do and I don't want to lose
money and Chris got Chris just you know
he just left Empire right to [__] with
me you know I'm managed by him and Brent
uh Brent's managers which is Thai based
in and Jane Andrews so like a lot of
people have banked on me you know Venice
music group is Distributing yeah that's
a distro company ever they dope my
friend uh tweeze over there yeah and um
and essentially they like they just help
you if you independent so a lot of
people taking time out putting Sweat
Equity into me and I just don't want him
to look stupid so like I gotta I gotta
follow through now yeah so I put [__]
I'm not ashamed of it I took every
dollar I had from all of these different
Ventures and said I'm banking on myself
with this music [__] so when I was
talking to glasses I'm like bro you know
you know cause you're one of the few
left real la media outlets for hip-hop
right like we are we are in a dire state
right we got you we got community in
them which uh homegrown radio show home
radio of course DJ head and of course
like Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck is that man
um but then it's like Gina when she's
not on no jumper I guess and like she's
not on the jumper now I think Gina just
started her uh own thing for her
apartment she should but she but she's
been doing that like she's been hard
like Gina's though she's all and the DJ
her and her the DJ friend they be doing
[__] so like and they should go crazy
yeah so uh West Coast Conference the
name of their show they were doing I
don't think it's happening anymore
though oh okay well do you see what I'm
saying we don't have a place to go all
the play all the outlets is on the East
Coast or in the South so for sure the
East Coast got a sewed up so this is
important to me because I'm like well
where did the little homies go tap in to
really because you know hip-hop you know
music history you know like you've been
outside and you really love this [__] so
I was like man who do I talk to who do I
go tell that hey look I make music I'm
out here and it's not bad who do you go
to that goes hey this [__] this [__] oh
right y'all should check this out
there's only like three people and I'm
not going I ain't gonna [__] on nobody
but I'm not going to the
you know I'm not you're not gonna catch
me on nobody like no defense to nobody
respectfully on how to get their money
but certain platforms you're not gonna
see me on because I don't I'm from a
certain element and I got a code I'm not
doing it right and so it makes it very
difficult so this was very important to
me I appreciate you coming through man
really important you're this is really
important well I appreciate it so you
know so the EP is June 23rd that's when
it's dropped June 25th dropping off the
the surprise single feature with the
music video and the EP all at once
um we got away from John you were
telling me about how you would uh well
he taught me how to invest in myself
okay so he he had originally taken you
serious once he saw you invest in myself
he did this movie your own feature and
all that so how does that spiral off so
what ends up happening is he goes I'm
gonna get you in the USC Film School
okay because like that's the dream is to
have John Singleton walk you into the
dean of USC film score and go which was
essentially what happened
um but I was still outside
um I think there was some and I always
say this I think I was he has a son
who's a wonderful human being and a
great you know director and Creator and
visual assist himself but their
relationship was tense
um and at that time it was tense it was
great after that but I think I at that
time I didn't have me and my pops wasn't
really you know he wasn't really around
at that moment so John kind of filled in
and I kind of filled in for that
relationship that he was not repairing
with his son in my opinion and I could
be wrong and we kind of like bumped
heads a lot because it it meant a lot to
us I didn't know that until later I just
thought he was trying to be my daddy
right I'm like [__] I don't like I
don't really want to hear none of that
yeah but at the end of the day he wanted
me to go to school and study filmmaking
but I wanted to study the business of
filmmaking because I knew how to make
movies right and he thought
and he was right that [__] was that's
not what he walked me in there to do
right and so he bumped head pretty bad
and we you know I ended up you know in
back in the streets again doing some
things and and he kind of was
disappointed and we kind of like got
into it and then you know we ended up
rerouting back to each other when I
auditioned because Kim Kim Hardin who's
his longtime casting director auditioned
on snowfall on snowfall she brought me
in originally the Tupac and then she was
like you dope like I need to [__] with
you for the Tupac movie yeah he was
going to do his Tupac movies I have the
original draft of his Tupac movie John
Singleton has a Tupac movie he has a
Tupac movie and the opening is
did that movie ever get made
because the Tupac movie we got was
decent let's not even do that it was
decent I would say it was decent I think
I think the Tupac movie we got it does
it does get some unwarranted hey I'm a
real [__] like I love any boom like he
did a lot for my section you know I
think he gets unwanted hey I actually
thought like when I saw it I was like I
mean I thought they casted the [__] out
of the Tupac but we know that Tupac's
biopic deserved the same level of NWA
residents even more I'll say that he
deserved a Gandhi level right a Malcolm
X level for sure he was that big of a of
a in that level of cinema right right
and that doesn't mean that Benny
couldn't do it but the budget limited
and all that that's what I'm saying yeah
I just think there was like budget
issues yeah you could kind of tell it's
like it should have gotten the same
respect as like Ali or something you
know yeah and so my my big homie um uh
legs recipes you know lucky was right
hands with Benny Boom so he's helped out
in the section A Lot shot the Waka
Flocka video in our section all that so
I show him no I actually thought it was
for like like knowing all the restraints
and [__] I thought it was I thought it
was solid and I thought that the no I
can't now I can't say that I don't feel
that way but I respect the kids the kid
who played Tupac though look just like
him he Jesus Kev you're such a Hip-Hop
Hip-Hop [__] just like he look like
him
that's like real hip-hop [__] to say
it's like are we sure Mike wasn't around
your mom brother but but you never know
what blessings you get from losing so
right that that Kim was like I need to
bring you in for something I think you'd
be the great the great as a lead for she
brought me in for the lead of snowfall
so they you got brought in to be
Franklin saint of initially oh I screen
tested okay yeah I was asked the screen
test yeah like I went in like and John
didn't even recognize me until the first
audition he was like holy [__] that's my
he was like that's my [__] son I just
think it's amazing he's like where have
you been he was like it was great it was
a beautiful reunion full circle moment
oh man I never forget it was Mother's
Day I just seen my um it was really
tough for me at that time like we were
my family was going through it and I put
all our business out but it was Mother's
Day and I just seen my mother and my
grandmother in a very compromising
situation like they were hiding like
like [__] was on first floor of an
apartment hiding the air mattress in the
bathroom type [__] you know on Mother's
Day and the next day was my audition for
snowfall and you knocked it out the park
obviously I did and then but I think
that the studio just wanted to go
another way because the two creators are
actually John Singleton and Erica Erica
Mario who's from Downey and um he never
gets enough credit for creating snowfall
it was him and John's initial idea yeah
John's like you know the name you know
yeah John's the name and put their DNA
together is what made the show and then
there's this um a showrunner who I'm not
going to mention who was kind of put in
position as a company man to kind of
manage them because they were they were
new to television and by the end of the
situation
um I just feel like uh a lot of the
decision making was not left up to John
and you know to my from from you know
for whatever better or worse but because
of that
um
certain things happen and that's fine
I'm okay with it because I think that
God works how he works the only thing I
would say is that gave me my my mentor
back like we got to get back cool and
that leadership and that foundation and
then and then Sundays that I missed and
that and being up under him and learning
in history and just everything more than
just filming television it was just a
beautiful like thing and I the only
thing I I missed that I wish I could
have done was become a big enough star
to to to give back to him like he's
giving us so many stars and respect and
love to them but he never got the
treatment that Scorsese got right he
never got the tree [__] he didn't even
get to see what snowfall became no he
didn't and and to my in my opinion I
just wish he would have had his Leo his
Robert De Niro right you know whoever
his his part like the guy who's booming
because he put him on come back and make
all his filmmaking dreams come true so
that's my only regret right right right
right right right you know but I mean it
ended up being like a greatly casted
show like yeah everybody in this show
can act they ass off uh the Idris dude
did a great job like I didn't even know
he was from the UK until I think I saw
saw interview after season two and I was
like this [__] kid's from London no
damn since the start hands down like
listen the original people who were
screen testing for for breakfast and the
Uncle Jerome uh was such a good Caster
oh yeah first of all looking Eamon
Joseph is a different level about he's a
different animal okay he's a different
animal same Beast like he's really what
Kobe be talking about that's him but
when I speak of dancing dancing earned
that amongst like he didn't just win
that against regular actor [__] he
went he wanted against the best of the
best out there like Kofi sirbo was up
for that role like I was a like it's
certain people you know like get busy I
heard like Dub C helped him with his
like West Coast style yeah dub was there
to do the training and um you know you
didn't help him at all but hey this
house of course I did but I but I never
took no credit because you know dub was
there every day but I just but initially
like when we were just like people don't
even remember
YG was originally Kevin oh I didn't know
that yeah and I remember right before
bro got you know he was in the studio
and got hurt yeah and then the studio
kind of freaked out I think wait so YG
was supposed to be in show and then he
got shot and then things I don't know
what but like after he got hurt he
wasn't Kevin no more oh wow and then it
was Kofi that's crazy that's real [__]
that's how this [__] go bro this is like
this whole I did not know why she was
supposed to be in a snowfall oh man
listen Kofi was Kofi and I were up for
Franklin Kobe ended up being the leader
um Queen sugar they moved me to Leon I
was Leon at some point however be the
lead to Leon to being to being Kevin
like then they made Kevin a bigger it
was crazy but you know for whatever the
reason that's what it was but what I'm
saying is damson is a star and I and
he's also my friend in in a in a good
dude like he just he fun he have a good
time but it's funny because I don't even
think people have really realized how
entertaining he is yet you know but but
it will come and I just met him at the
uh Tyler the Creator show and he was
super nice super nice guy yeah he's a
fun guy he was just there by himself
enjoying the Tyler show yeah that's
dancing dancing like that he he's really
a Charming funny dude when you get the
script and you realize your guy is about
to get killed off what's that like as an
actor I don't feel [__] [__] from the
streets that [__] I'm just wondering I
was glad to get my family out the hood
right
I was wondering when I watched like my
favorite shows right and like you'll see
like one of these beloved characters get
killed like on the actor side when they
get that script and they're like oh
well so Kev I don't know if you know
this I'm black
we die in everything
so so I'm just used to this [__] no I'm
just kidding um I knew already right so
you had an idea that John well listen
there's certain things that I'm just not
going to talk about right now because I
I want to I don't want it to overshadow
what I'm doing with music what I'm doing
with film and television because when I
talk about that I want to talk about it
from a place of pure true for [__]
can't say I'm hating right so I gotta
win first but the the way that I could
say without being a snitch-ass
[__] is being like other things
happen some real situations happen that
I didn't agree with how certain people
handled them John went to bat for me and
they found a way to be like hey like
we're not sure if we want to keep them
and John Candyman was like do you want
me to fight for you do you want to stay
on and John and I had so many we had
movies with Netflix going we had all
types of [__] going on like a movie like
we had all types of things like writing
and directing going on and so he was he
was like do you want me to to go to bat
for you and I and I was like no I don't
want to be where I'm not wanting right
and he's like well it's not that they
don't want you they just want to you
know they wanna they wanna get they want
to they're scared they want to get you
out of here because you know whatever
and I said
I'll be all right I'm straight bro I
don't I'm good and I was good I ended up
as a lead on raising Canyon so and for
me other actors they operate out of fear
because it's just like music like you
you know when people come bring in your
mixtape and [__] like they trying so
hard they love this [__] so hard they
they work so hard and they don't get
nothing back from it you have one
opportunity to rap in front of Kev you
got one opportunity to get in front of
like Kanye or somebody and do your [__]
and then that could change your whole
life
but I've been blessed enough to to know
my Divine ordainment like I would people
love me at home bro like where I'm from
I'm solid I'm I'm I could be on the I
could be down on down digging the dirt
and [__] respect me because of what
I've done in real life right my mama
loved me my Grandma loved me my section
loved me you feel me so
whether I book a role or not first of
all [__] know I'm cold with this movie
[__]
as you can see if I want to rap I could
rap good right see I can do whatever I
really want to do so everything is just
timing every but I feel bad for other
people because there's a desperation and
it's sad because people take advantage
of that